so i first met
uh this next presenter uh when she
attended one of the r workshops i was
teaching
and recently i was very excited to be
like hey let's have you speak at this
conference because you do really cool
work in a
very public-facing field so i'm very
excited to have her here
and she wants everyone to know that she
spent a summer
in north dakota
on an internship
and she was there to write a story about
a small town that had a population of
30 people
and it says while visiting the town for
interviews
she increased the asian represent
representation in that town from zero to
three percent
so please everyone
welcome to the stage jasmine
thank you jared thank you for inviting
me and thank you everyone for being here
i'm excited
my name is jasmine han i'm a data
reporter with bloomberg industry group
um we are part of bloomberg
okay additional fun fact while i was in
north dakota i did grow a liking of
american food because i'm
originally from china i have an asian
taste bud
um
anyway um i uh i moved to the us in 2014
for journalism school and now i'm based
in maryland in my free time i like
cooking
plan plans um climbing indoors and
doodling
so
on to today's topic
data journalists are toolbox
so a lot of people i mean in real life
you know new people i mean ask me what i
what do i do i tell them i'm a data
journalist they give me a very confused
look
um because there's notion
at least in the past that
journalists are good at words but not at
mass or anything in adjacent
but there's actually a bigger and bigger
community of people who like doing both
telling stories and
do math or coding programming
so yeah today i'm here to show you that
yes data journalism is a thing it's cool
and then how we data journalists use r
so alright so what is data journalism
and why should i care
i don't know how you all keep track of
the covet pandemic but i keep coming
back to this new york times landing page
is pretty much all information i need
there are a lot of uh
independent efforts tracking code out
there but i find theirs
to be the most intuitive and most
comprehensive and they also
the data quality is very trustworthy
because uh they have
a team dedicated to the scripting the
cleaning and the reporting etc
um so based on the data uh they keep
track of they did a series of stories on
the impact of the covet pandemic
including this one that shows
um racial or ethnical uh inequality
of covet contraction rates and including
this one which is a interactive map that
allows breeders to
just look at how full the hospital ico
icus are in your own neighborhood
so this series won at the 2021 pulitzer
prize in public service
and the jury said that they filled a
data vacuum that helped
the general public to be better prepared
and product protected
so yeah data journalism helps fill a gap
of information they turn data into
information that can be used by the
general public it's a public
service and in addition data journalism
allows us to tell stories that go beyond
words
and readers are put directly into the
story and they can tell stories of their
own and i'm using a quote by aaron
williams he's a former washington post
data reporter who did this beautiful
piece
that used maps to illustrate the trends
in
america's diversity but also segregation
and at the end of the story he allows
readers
uh to zoom in on your own neighborhood
uh an area of your own interest
and tell your own story by gaining like
insights that's relevant to your own
experience
so
yeah and last but not least
data journalism exposes systematic
problems in ways that
journalists just can't otherwise
for example
this investigation by the atlanta
general constitution
exposed a broken system that allows
doctors
discipline for sexually abusing their
patients
to continue to practice
so
the reporters scraped
doctor disciplinary action documents
from state bar websites
around the country all of them
they collected it must have been over
a hundred thousand documents
i need to double check numbers but it
was a huge body of documents
and they developed a regression model to
filter down these documents based on
keywords
uh down to about 10
uh that were potentially
uh sexual abuse offense
and then the reporters batted these 10
documents and drove the rest of the
reporting from there
so if it weren't for this of this data
it wouldn't have been possible to prove
that this is a systematic problem
happening nationally on a large scale
and it weren't for the the model
it would have been impossible for humans
to go through all of these arguments
and sometimes when the data is really
big it gets journalists around the globe
to collaborate and reveal the rich and
powerful sturdy secrets
so this investigation by
international
consortium of investigative journalists
along with about 100 media partners
they used
a leak
leaked documents about 11.5 million
documents
that exposed the secret financial
dealings uh by
some of the most powerful people around
the world so the icij
built a neo4j graph database
um
that
uh that allowed reporters to uncover
basically relationships between
key stakeholders key entities etc etc
so
yeah as a result of the story um
revealed companies that helped syria's
deathly ear war
or
a network of people close to vladimir
putin that secretly moved billions of
dollars through banks and offshore
companies
and then a secret company
of
former uh prime minister of iceland and
he had to resign over the citizens rage
and protests so basically as a result of
this investigation
governments fell
authorities launched
tax probes criminal investigations
so it is very impactful
so hopefully i have
so far convinced you that data
journalism is very cool and very
impactful
and so what does it have to do with art
we're in our conference so we're going
to talk about art
here's a life cycle
of data analysis project
and uh
data journalism project project shares
very much a parallel between these steps
so the point of showing this chart is to
say that a lot of these steps we can do
in r
so we start from an idea we need to
understand the data and then
prepare the data
sometimes script the data clean the data
and then we do exploratory analysis
maybe in this analysis do some
visualization
and then we validate the data
what we're finding
sometimes using our work by talking to
sources
or subject matter
experts and then moving on to the
production phase we produce
visualizations and then
a story of words
so for example i want to highlight a
project i did about few years ago
on
tariffs so i learned so much about what
art can do
from this project
in 2018 former president donald trump
imposed tariffs on imported goods
of steel of aluminum or chinese goods
so that means that u.s companies trying
to import these goods
will
will be faced with
increased costs so they're
they're being challenged
um
but
the administration does allow companies
to sort of submit a request saying can
we be exempted
you know what we want to import is not
manufactured in the us you know
reasons like that
so they can submit this request form
um in addition
they allow third parties to object to
submitted requests
so some companies might
say you're a liar
we actually manufacture this in the u.s
you can buy from us so you shouldn't be
exempted
just for an example uh and then the uh
administration or you know the commerce
department then make decisions uh for
these requests
and they issue this decision in a
decision memo
pdf documents so
they actually post these documents on
individual dockets for these tariffs on
regulations.gov
so we were able to
scrape these documents uh process them
analyze the data in it in them and then
uh
did a series of stories
for example this one that looks at
how corporate america is sort of on the
losing end in a bid to ease the tariffs
and how
u.s manufacturers that are seeking
relief
are just left in limbo
in the backlogs and red tape
and we found some of the top automakers
are imploring
to get relief from chinese imports
including so tesla's requested relief
from
a product they call that serves as a
car's brain so that's very essential to
uh their product
and then also how pet supply industry
also took a big blow
so cute um
here's how we did the scraping we use
these libraries
and here is our repo screenshot we have
several
scripting
scripting scripts but
to just boil down to uh
to one line of code what's most
important is this line so we sort of
piece together a
url for the epi call
then we use the get function to retrieve
that document
and then we use xml parse and then xml
to list function
to parse it and then we then we are able
to sort of pick you know what we need
and then you might notice that we use
sysdot sleep and try catch a lot
because these prevent us from being seen
as a bot and then get blocked from the
website server and then try catch allows
the code to keep running when we're hit
by an error
and in processing we relied heavily on
spring r and pdf tools
here's an example of a request form you
can see it's very heavily um
heavily styled a lot of merge cells blah
blah blah
so it's not the clean data frames that
um
we're used to seeing
but deep down it's basically a great
system right you have row number cell
number et cetera et cetera
so
to extract the information we sort of
need to
use these section
uh
you know the section numbers
and then some of the keywords to sort of
serve as the road sign almost to
tell us you know where the information
we need is at
in this grid system
so we used uh which and grep to find
these row signs and then uh you know get
back that index that row and cell and
then retrieve from there
and this is an example
of a decision memo
and
there's some pattern here they always
reveal the decision at the end of the
at the end of the letter
is big x
so i approve denying this exclusion
request
um
so what we are looking for here is that
big x
so
we did with these pdfs we first of all
parse them with the pdf text function
and turn it into
like a vector of sentences like each row
is one
uh
one like each row serves as one uh
row
and then we find this uh big x right
space x space
using regular expressions so we get to
that line we want
so that's very uh that's vastly
simplifying the process but
i think i've included the keep
information here
and then after the scraping and
processing right we sort of
dump the data tables
into a postgres sql database
which we then are able to access via the
rodbc library
and for the analysis
we built a shinier dashboard that
allows us to do
preliminary or
exploratory analysis
keep updating it based on the most
updated data and we had relied heavily
on
high charter library to produce
interactive
visualizations
so
for example
we looked at steel exemptions how many
of them got
how many requests gone the decision how
many didn't
how long they had to wait for a decision
so these terms informed the story on the
u.s manufacturers facing
backlog in red tea
and here
is a map
that shows which congressional districts
these requesting companies are from so
we can infer okay which legislators
might be
interested in
in this issue
and then we also included some charts on
top companies which are the top
companies submitting requests
and
we actually also included a searchable
table that allows us to search company
names
uh so that's a quickly
that's a quick tool for us to find you
know the automakers and pet industry
companies and it was very useful for our
for those stories
and
down to the graphics so
we are
uh
we have a very small graphics team
uh in our newsroom
so
a lot of times my colleague
my colleague aaron and i we produce sort
of a bare bone version
uh and then hand it off to graphics for
uh for
for styling and we use these uh
libraries a lot so for the maps i
believe i use tmap for this one and
tigress is also often used so we can
because graphics artists it's really
hard for them to sort of hand draw all
these vectors uh as maps but we can
easily do an r and then hand it off to
them
and um and for charts what i really like
about ggplot2
it allows you a lot of customization
so
i we were actually um able to style it
exactly as
how our style guide
would require like including you know
the font
sizes colors
for each section
so it's really neat and i can pretty
much
get the charts
90 of the way
uh before i i can hand it off to our
graphics colleagues so it's a huge boost
in productivity
um there's so much more i wanted to talk
about but because of the
time limit um
but uh feel free to uh reach out keep in
touch and
yeah thank you
you